The Harvard jazz band is just a standard
jazz band with 17 musicians what makes
it unique is like the students
they're very passionate for music and
if you ask them what are their
concentrations you know it goes from
government to physics to computer
science it's an unusual I would say big band
the reason we chose Cassandra
Wilson for our residency
first this series is special because it's
celebrating women in jazz and Cassandra
Wilson is one of the most singular voices of
her generation who has been able to
channel the huge legacy of her
predecessors going back even to Charlie
Parker to Duke Ellington she's one of
the jazz masters that we have working today
this is going to be a privilege
for the students who have someone like
Cassandra Wilson here to share with them
her incredible knowledge about this
musical tradition but not only jazz she
has been someone that has always been
curious to learn about other musical
traditions and trying to incorporate
that into the work that she does so we
hope that the Harvard students can
benefit a lot from all of this knowledge
that's she's sharing that's why I consider
the students fortunate to have someone of her
caliber and her stature to come and share with them